I don't think anything is a good thing
or a bad thing I think you should spend
plenty of time with your girlfriend and
I think you should spend plenty of time
listening to my crap and getting better
what you should cut out is all the other
stuff like you Bowl do you play games on
your phone
are you watching house of cards Breaking
Bad there's other things to cut up
anxious
it's the
yeah
I told you this was last Monday morning
in her life of inner nation it's me Gary
listen a year ago ironically 100
episodes ago I set on a mission to to
show you and document the way I ran my
life as an entrepreneur as a businessman
as a person really I really set out to
make a video series that would have
inspired me as a 15 16 17 year old I
think there's a lot of content out there
that helps people that learn by tactics
the the reverse of how I learn I learn
by watching and pattern recognition and
picking up on vibe I didn't need the
things that they taught in school to
become an entrepreneur I needed to see
somebody living it doing it and so as I
pondered what I was going to do for
episode 100 I realized that I didn't
want to do anything nothing special
nothing fancy just a quick little thank
you just a quick little acknowledgement
that your comments means so much to me
as some of you have noticed that started
getting more active in the YouTube
comments and I will continue to do that
you know I just uh I just wanted to say
thanks to all of you I hope you've
gotten as much out of this as I've
gotten from you guys in return and and I
promise you that I'll continue to do it
continue to bring it sorry for the very
basic episode 100 but to be very frank
it feels super honest and super real and
super to the way I actually roll so
that's how we're going to do it but wait
till you see episode 101 your bad word
oh and one last thing what's the
number-one thing you've learned from
Daily Beast's so far
backwards that every way to work and
ever meet it as an erase you got you
ever not beating I love you
yeah yeah